the u.s marshals are looking for a man
who was originally in trouble for bank
robbery
tonight they're asking for your help the
i-team's vanessa murphy continues our
vegas fugitive series as she tells all
about roland hill
court records reveal roland hill surfed
his time in prison for a bank robbery
and was close to finishing probation
but according to this deputy u.s marshal
who asked
not to be identified hill disappeared
he is a fugitive from justice right now
this case goes back to october of 2016.
federal prosecutors say hill and a
friend robbed this bank on flamingo near
pecos
the friend yelled at tellers to give him
all their money and
hill stood guard over customers in the
lobby while holding his waistband
investigators say they stole nearly 27
thousand dollars but were later arrested
hill was sentenced to 27 months in
prison and
three years of probation which this
deputy u.s
marshal says he did not complete he
stopped
obeying the rules and
appeared via video conference for the
initial appearance
for the judge to say okay this is what
they're accusing you of
and my decision is that you go back into
some form of confinement be in the
halfway house
and he wanted no parts of that
he tells the i-team he's been searching
for hill since january
the 34 year old man may frequent the
area near nellis air force base and
desert inn and nellis
and he has ties to both southern nevada
and california
in a letter which was submitted to the
court in 2018
hill shared how he had a tough
upbringing and struggled with addiction
but had turned his life around in prison
he also pledged it would be the last
time
he would be incarcerated according to
the u.s
marshals service concerns remain about
drug use
and weapons he has a penchant
for domestic violence but then also
his criminal history includes aggravated
assault
robbery
resisting public officers or peace
officers and
things like that and so that heightens
that
threat to public safety the u.s marshals
are asking hill to turn himself
in or for members of the public to
report
if they see him vanessa murphy 8 news
now
so if you do have any information on
roland hills whereabouts you're urged to
call the u.s marshal's office
the number there on your screen
702-388-6355